we're celebrating this half-hour some
more of our discussions around the 25th
anniversary of the Dave Ramsey show and
as you know the 25th anniversary the
Dave Ramsey show doesn't occur only on
the back of Dave Ramsey we've had a
whole lot of people on our team over a
whole lot of years 25 years helping us
grow this and in the studio to talk
about some of the old days is one of our
operating board members if you didn't
know we have 10 folks on our operating
board three of them are ladies and evps
our CMO an EVP over the church area and
the EVP over the consumer channel is
suzanne sims executive vice president
and so we thought it'd be fun because
she started here a long time ago as an
attempt and further back than that we
can go if we need to but uh we thought
be fun to get her on here because she
came up through the ranks of the
broadcast area they're what we call the
radio department in those days so
welcome thank you I'm so excited so very
honored all these years is your first
time put the microphone on it is and
it's probably best that way there's been
a lot of been a lot of trash-talking
around it I can tell you that for sure
they've been giving you a hard time
good to know you know they've been
giving you a hard time nobody did it to
your face yeah they did a little bit to
my face I'm I'm a little bit of a loose
cannon don't have a great filter so
there's always this concern about giving
Suzanne a microphone give give them the
dump button finger hovered over the dump
button in there so just in case but so
how long tell folks how long you been
here I've been here 16 years I started
in May of 2001 and that was the tenth
part where I was two days a week I love
my story because it's not just my story
it's like a really awesome story for the
company and there's like a whole handful
of these stories those of us that
started in the early days and we did
whatever we whatever needed to be done
we didn't have titles we didn't have
official roles some of us we just came
in and we were scrappy and we did
what needed to be done and I was doing
administrative work two days a week and
you stopped by my little tiny cube one
day and said have you thought about
working full-time because we really need
some people and some full-time roles and
long story short I went full-time in
September of that year okay and Suzanne
and Laura Johnson who used to be the
phone screen Associate Producer now is
in charge of all things video around
here as far as the broadcast stop parts
of it go you guys were in youth group
together yes we were we've grown up
together she was in my wedding back in
the day and so both and Sharon and I
worked with the youth we were like young
adults working with the teenagers back
in those days so you guys were in the
youth group only working with it and
then both of you ended up working here
and several others from the youth group
ended up working here over the years but
come in you know I just remembered you
know Suzanne was very bright she had a
big intellect always big smart girl in
college in high school and all this kind
of stuff so you know somebody said
something about you know we need a temp
in here to do something and Suzanne can
do that I said yeah she'll be great at
that but then you know you got in there
and you started having fun and that
evolved over the years through quite a
radio career over the last 16 years so
you went from temp to doing what you had
a vision for a role we called it
director of affiliate relations and no
one else in the industry had ever done
this and to this day has never done this
you said Suzanne your job is to build
relationships with our radio stations
with the decision makers and get to know
them and super serve them because we are
self syndicated and we fight for every
clear we get we fight for every radio
station on our list because we're up
against huge companies that own that own
their own radio shows and and we're up
against them and so if we build
relationship we do everything
relationally here with vendors with
clients just everything we do and you
saw the need to do that in the radio
industry and how effective that would be
and it has been because they've become
our friends so your first role is
affiliate relations yes I hadn't
forgotten that you know it from admin to
that really yeah yeah
so you're like 20-something years old
and you start calling these these
corporate geeks and that's radio
stations who sometimes are not nice and
sometimes they're very nice people but
initially they like you want to build
relationships bite this a little bit
afraid of it they don't know is
necessarily what to do with it because
no other radio show ever ever tried to
build a relationship with them nobody
ever cared about them as a person right
just trying to a transaction right mmm
okay and so you your first what did you
do doing that at first I had a
spreadsheet and I would call and I would
do my best to figure out who the
decision-maker was that was not always
easy because a lot of times there were a
lot of people wearing multiple hats at
stations but if you could figure it out
I would just learn about them like who's
their favorite sports team and when's
their birthday and when's their spouses
birthday and they would get a birthday
card from us on their birthday and their
spouse would get a birthday card from us
and we would just find ways to super
serve them and I had a regular schedule
of when I would contact them and just
see how they were doing and see how the
station was doing and I would keep up
with the ratings on each of those
stations so we could have you know a an
intelligent conversation about what was
going on in their market and what their
world was looking like and and how we
were a part of that and usually there
was a play to get us a better timeslot
you know about by watching those ratings
and so that was all a part of the job
and it was all done very relationally
and there are a few women in the
industry very few very few and so I
found that you know a lot of these
program directors they were the ones I
was calling on initially they would sit
in these you know control rooms all day
with very little interaction with anyone
and so when a woman would call with a
nice tone and caring about them it it
caused them to actually spend time
talking to me which really baffled my
boss at the time bill Hampton believed
they would take my because he couldn't
get him to talk to him so you ended up
actually several years in a row winning
the award of
top female and radio one of the one of
radios most influential women yeah they
do radio ain't does that that that issue
every year and I've been honored to be a
part of that for sure because with us
being self syndicated the industry
doesn't always know what to do with us
we do everything so different and the
titles and roles that we have are not
exactly like the titles and roles of all
these other radio companies but they
have been recognizing us for a few years
now cool stuff Suzanne Simms joins us
for a half hour as we walk down memory
lane just a little bit here on our 25th
anniversary she is one of our operating
board members an executive vice
president the company these days been
with us 16 years all the way from a temp
admin to one of the top roles in the
entire organization today and broadcast
is just one of the many things that
falls under her purview today but she's
been with us on the radio thing all the
way up so interesting to talk about and
think about where we've come from to be
where we are today we'll talk about that
a little bit more in this next segment
this walk down memory lane right here on
the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]
and it's doctor les parrot in Seattle 25
years
are you kidding me that's an incredible
milestone and it is such an honor to get
to celebrate this date you and your team
have produced one of the great radio
broadcasts of all time and I got to tell
you it's such an honor to be on it on
occasion and to share the speaking stage
with you
congratulations friend you're amazing
Thank You les les is one of our speakers
at the Smart Conference always speaks on
marriage and is very popular and he and
Rachel Cruz will be doing a money--and
marriage event and just outside of
Nashville here on in Murfreesboro
Tennessee November the 13th that gives
Rachel time to get back from maternity
leave and so yeah they come and make
that happen guys that's a great event
you don't want to miss out on that we're
doing a walk down memory lane here as we
do 25th anniversary celebration all
throughout this year coming to a head
actually up in September we're gonna
stop talking about it after September
for those of you that are sick of it but
Suzanne Sims is with us our one of our
operating board members an executive
vice president with our company one of
the three ladies that sits on our
operating board and was has been awarded
the one of the most influential women in
radio award several times and started
with us in temp admin role worked up
through a director of a filler affiliate
relations and we were just talking about
the old day so how many affiliates did
we have when you came on board we had
about 30 30 ish 30 and we have 588 today
today we're in seven out of the top ten
markets and 20 of the top 25 markets and
Phoenix Arizona now KTAR is our top and
I just saw some ratings the other day of
that we just owned that market ratings
wise Thank You Phoenix we appreciate you
we number one talk show in the city in
this time slot and so if you're
listening to someone else in this time
slot you're not listening the number one
show thank you guys we appreciate you
making us that will brag on ourselves
enough do we know we don't it's and it's
really exciting
happened even in the past year in a
couple years like to be in all those top
markets and to be on good stations with
good listenership it's it is really
really fun and really I mean we took we
would get to take almost any timeslot
almost anywhere just to get our foot in
the door back in the day now we're
pretty picky because we're kind of the
800-pound gorilla nowadays and you know
if they want to here is still hardcore
in the early days though Suzanne we need
the live time slot let's work on the
live time slot because you always knew
and to this day it holds true when we're
on live our listeners can interact with
us and we are a caller driven show our
show is about their lives
that's our content and that's the
richness of our show and so yeah you're
right but we still push them really hard
so you moved from affiliate relations
and all not you know to start with you
were just kind of calling in building
relationships we're talking about that
but later on it came to really you
managing that relationship and having
some real difficult conversations with
people trying to break a contract and
some stuff like that and a hold of the
society you started coming out kind of
the hard but here I mean you're tough
tough it's a tough business it's a
rough-and-tumble business innit yes we
were just amazed at how contracts meant
nothing to some of these people like
we're such relational people integrity
is a big deal for us and we were amazed
at how many times we would have a
contract and they would call and say hey
we're gonna drop your show we would say
no no you you have to carry us another
here look at what you signed and so
there was some of that we've had to deal
with what you moved from there and what
was your next title what did you do the
next one was vice-president of broadcast
we started calling it the broadcast
department and so I was VP of broadcast
so I was overseeing the business side of
the radio show which is the the
advertising that we sell in the way that
we monetize the show in addition to
those relationships okay so you started
running the PNL at that point and so
that all the national ad accounts the
local affiliates and the ads that we do
there I'll fall under that affiliate
relations
so Brian Mayfield was I think brought
into cell at that time right yes he was
during that time and he has ended up
being the vice president as you've moved
on that over the entire consumer
division yeah he's done an amazing job
he's just taken it to a whole new level
you know he has he really has but back
in those days um somebody came up and I
don't remember where this came from with
this idea to do something that had never
been done in the industry and that was
the affiliate executive council talk
about what that is and how that came
about because from a business
perspective that's kind of interesting
yeah and again it's never been
replicated but and no one ever will
because it requires too much effort but
we're willing to do that and it's paid
off it's been amazing my memory was that
there was an executive in the industry
there were several but there was a key
executive in the industry Sean Compton
that had a conversation with you one
time and said listen if you could figure
out how to take the decision-makers
specifically program directors from the
radio stations and just pull them in
once a year and really Wine and Dine
them and super serve them and give them
a chance to have a place to talk to you
and give you feedback that would be huge
for you relationally and you see things
really big so in typical day fashion you
took his little minuscule idea that he
pitched at you and you came back to us
and said guys were blowing this up we're
gonna do a five star event we're gonna
bring in at the time the first time we
did it ten years ago we brought them
into Nashville into our home turf and we
wined and dined them for a couple of
days and took really good care of them
made them feel really special but also
gave them great content they got to hear
you teach some great entree leadership
lessons they've gotten to hear from
other speakers over the years and from
some of our personalities and we give
them a forum to talk to us and give us
feedback on what they are dealing with
the challenges they have at their radio
stations and how we can help and it's
been amazing we do a quarterly
conference call with them where we do
the similar kind of thing we give them
good content we hear from them and then
once a year we have that five
which if we're being honest we don't
mind that event we have a lot of fun
they've become our friends and so it's
it's having fun with friends but also
it's really intense relationship
building and we've been doing that 10
years to the point that there were only
two people because the radio business is
a lot of turnover they're only two
people been to every single event they
both retired this yes they did
Robert hallmark out in Texas and Henry
Capone yeah with our affiliate in Grand
Rapids Michigan
Robertson Midland Odessa and has retired
but we're having Robert back just
because yeah he has nothing to do with
nothing now but we just love Robert he's
coming this year to the one but you know
you guys I mean you and Amy Severson
took that thing and Brian and just
jacked it up to where it was it is a
world-class five-star event I mean like
to give you guys an example we rented
out Ellis Island with the Statue of
Liberty we were in New York one year and
did a private dinner in the intake hall
in Ellis Island so picture this we all
get on a private yacht and ride across
the you know the bay with the Statue of
Liberty at night sitting there as we
come up we get off the dock there's
candle line lined walkways up we come in
there's actors playing musical
instruments that look like immigrants as
if you were just walking in during the
Ellis Island days and then we go in and
have a five-star meal in there that was
absolutely incredible
and we've done stuff like that that are
just world-class type stuff it's been a
lot of fun to do yeah but but nobody
does that in the radio business no not
anymore most industries don't do that
I mean it's just it's unheard of but we
take those relationships seriously and
and it's paid off because the same ones
come back year after year and if they
get pressure to take our show off the
air that's gonna be hard for them to do
because we're their friends and we've
poured into them and we do a great job
on the air too but you know but the
radio business is real fickle and
sometimes people just with the flip of a
switch will take your head off you know
and so we weren't trying to move
somebody into doing something that they
shouldn't do I mean but but we just
wanted consideration yeah because we
weren't always given that
as a standalone self syndicate reserved
it yeah yeah very cool stuff well
congratulations an ami Severson that
started that with that has just gotten a
big big promotion and she's moving over
to a vice president in a whole other
area that company and she's another one
just like you that started out at the
very bottom of the whole process so that
we've done it we've done this together
that's how this show has happened guys
is people like Amy and Laura and Blake
and Suzanne and you know James and Kelly
all these guys this show has done that
because of the quality of team behind
the scenes I get all the credit cuz I'm
in the spotlight but the truth is it's
not me this is the Dave Ramsey show hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]